hello hello to everyone out there on
YouTube it's looking like chess comm is
not back up and running but you know
what we set the time for 6:30 it's now
6:40 the match is actually scheduled to
start in four short minutes I have no
idea what's going to happen that is an
advertisement playing on my phone where
I have the chat pulled up here so we're
just going to to hang out for a second
I'm gonna talk to guys a little bit
about what we hopefully have going on
tonight I am becoming more more doubtful
that it's going to happen as scheduled
it might in fact just be delayed or you
know maybe we'll just have to reschedule
for a whole nother day but it was going
to be a really big event the Charlotte
chess Center actually has a really
impressive lineup tonight
consisting of of course their resident
Grandmaster Daniel na Radetzky
grandmaster andrew tang international
master and Vijay master
Brandon Jacobsen and Aaron Jacobson
respectively the big Jacobson brothers
they also have FM mark Plotkin a
national master named Yong Chi Juan
Carlos Perdomo an international master
Robbie Adamson feed a master national
master Dominique Myers and that a
variety of players so I've never heard
of to round out their team
I assume all from the Charlotte
Charlotte chess center meanwhile on our
team we have the number 32
I believe chess player in the world Liam
Lee followed by the number 33 chess
player in the world it might be like one
or two off there Geoffrey Zhang to head
our team so pretty good stuff and now I
don't mean to offend anyone here but in
my opinion this is kind of looking like
the matchup of you know the the
high-class chess players you know Liam
Lee Jeffrey Zhang you know 2700 Plus
really pushing for top ten in the world
at some point in their life against you
know the the internet guys you know
Danya
and it's key setting internet chest comm
blitz records every other day
Andrew tang battling magnus carlsen just
a little bit ago over only chess you
know these these are the the stars of
the internet versus some of the world's
best over the board players and so we'll
see if Liam Lee and Jeffrey Zhang can
can take them out if you're just joining
us here
of course we are hoping that the match
can go on as scheduled but it does
appear that chests calm servers are
entirely down I checked their Twitter to
see if they had anything to say about it
and they didn't I don't know where else
I can really look for information on
this so we're hoping that the chest out
calm servers come back the match is
actually scheduled to start in less than
a minute that's obviously not going to
happen if the servers are all down but
we'll see what happens why is it
referred to as Liam Lee instead of
laQuan Liam I have had extended
conversations with Ben Simon on this one
and it turns out it's just the rest of
the world that's that's wrong here he's
at we have asked Liam Lee personally
which name he would like to go by and he
says to call him
Liam Lee instead of laQuan Liam I
believe Lacroix is or Kwang is like I
don't know Leigh is his last name
this much I know and in the Vietnamese
culture the last name is sometimes said
first I think that's the way to do it
but generally when they Americanize it
they they go in the first name last name
order as as most Americans do so Liam is
his first name Leigh is his last name
so he goes by Liam Leigh but yeah hello
everyone thanks for for checking in here
it is now officially 6:45 the match was
slated to start at this exact moment
refreshing chess calm here it looks like
it's it's still down but I'm not sure
what to do about this I'm gonna wait for
Mike comer to officially cancel it
before I do anything
in the meantime let's continue looking
at our impressive lineup we have of
course international master a addition
to this team hon smoke Nieman
Hans Nieman of course now a veteran of
the US Junior Championships also has his
own twitch channel over at saucy Moke I
think I'm getting that right
saucy MOOC what about Ben Feingold I
believe
Ben Feingold has started his own chess
Center he is not really a part of the
Charlotte chess center or the st. Louis
chess club at this current moment he has
his own chest center in Atlanta
I believe the Chess Club and scholastic
center of Atlanta oh and sorry I've got
that wrong Hans Neiman has actually
officially changed his twitch name he
used to be saucy MOOC which is a fun
little name now he is just I am Hans
Neiman on Twitch we also have
international master Aaron Grubin Skype
Webster student we have national master
Gopal Menon who has also got a twitch
channel so if you want to check him out
he's over on professor daddy with an eye
on twitch that is PR o Fe SS o r da DDI
we also have Forrest Shen playing for us
as well as Julian pearl Aiko these two
players playing for us in both of our
previous matches and events I believe we
also have national master Nicolas
Rosenthal the third streamer on the
roster for the night
Nick does stream over on his twitch
account called Froehlich 6767
that's FR o li ke 6767
then we have aditya pono Kumari who I
believe is a Wash U student on the Washu
chess team we have Luke Yi playing for
us as well a local kiddo who is rising
soaring really through those ranks see
I'm sure he's just about to hit national
master he's the type of kid who just
goes up a hundred points every time you
look at his rating we also have Eric
kochenko over 2000 now these days a
chess club employee playing for us
as well as the sushi panda Akshay has
been replaced by Vinny thready
toddy party of course another local
player in our select chess program we
also have been Lou playing as well as
Arjun pari
and rounding out the roster the one and
only leader of the video department here
Jonathan strands rounding out the team
so I'm gonna refresh tress calm again
see what else is new and it's looking
like it's still going to be down still
down unfortunate
that's the Asian culture basically yeah
I mean use whatever source you like but
Bensimon is is really a stickler for
getting these names right and he has
personally asked Liam Lee what he would
like to be called and he has chosen
Liam Lee so this this is his choice
also the the kuan-yin is really just a
middle name from what I understand and
even in the Vietnamese culture he would
go by lately M without without the clock
so I don't know where where this naming
system actually started with everybody
calling this guy like wrongly M but he
goes by Liam Lee to the best of my
knowledge well okay here we are hoping
against hope that chess comm gets their
stuff together here two together
together
let's check their Twitter again see
what's going on maybe I'll pull up some
UPS forums see if they have anything to
say
okay no they they're just still
promoting their events I guess that was
probably like a schedule tweet guess
they scheduled tweet chest comm is down
will it start your guess is as good as -
eesh I'm waiting on the word from Mike
to see what the plan is here I feel like
there might not be a plan let me send
that guy a text see what he thinks
alright the text has been sent to the
one and only st. Louis chess club team
manager Michael J comer we will see the
match will be canceled at 7:10 p.m. if
not resolved alright we are fill-in time
we've got 20 minutes to fill you guys
what do you want to talk about you want
to talk about some chests we can talk
about some chests so the chat doesn't
cover the board short answer no long
answer yeah kinda but I would have to uh
I would have to make all those changes
before the stream got started I did not
realize that the chat would cover the
board I assume you're watching like on
on mobile or something and when you when
you tilt it or when you go to landscape
mode the chat kind of covers okay so
I've just received the official email
here chess comm / life has crashed the
first two rounds are null and void you
heard it here first first two rounds
canceled null and void the event will
officially begin at 7:10 Central Time
that is in 19 minutes let's talk about
our favorite foods I've recently been
introduced to these things called crepes
and they are the best thing I've ever
eaten in my life and I I don't know how
how I made it this far in my life
without eating crepes on a regular basis
but now that is where the majority of my
spending money goes
some recent Alekhine jives by magnus I
actually have not been following the
magnus carlsen invitational too closely
i know that he just got beat by a ding
Loran or something three two one you
guys are too kind
I saw you saying nice things about my
classes too it goes straight to my ego
and makes me in sufferable so stop
saying such nice things or else everyone
in my life will hate me
um too sad you're awake it's 1:50 a.m.
in Germany you started eating your
chocolate because of waiting for so long
well apologies hopefully your chocolate
is offering you some consolation
once again it's really just down to a
chest calm here is like wow it looks
like there's a weird video glitch going
on where my laptop is like dancing back
and forth what's going on here I don't
know
well here we wait 17 minutes until we
find out if the match is canceled or
live we are giving them some time to
figure it out
ah you've switched to the Cairo switch
to the Cairo another victim
now you're suckered in for life you'll
never be able to change so for those of
you been following these Kerr lectures I
can only make one move that's so said I
can't even can I pull up an analysis
book how limited am i without internet
access here start I can't make moves I'm
so sad I can't even talk about chess so
sad so so sad anyways those of you
falling in care lectures c6 d4 d5 be on
the lookout for the fantasy variation I
think that's what I'm gonna have up next
on deck for you guys here so what's
gonna be on deck for you guys
wait a second that was a good noise that
was a noise I heard a noise is a back is
it back I think it's back wait it was
back and now it's gone it was back and
now it's gone that is just so so sad
isn't it so so sad
did I make my face too big as that was
that what's wrong here
I don't understand I don't know I don't
know these things I'm not trained in
fixing color range
colorspace what's happening is
everything shaking so much I'm so scared
I'm so scared
well guess it's just gonna stay that way
it's that horribly distracting it seems
horribly distracting doesn't it if I
make myself slightly smaller things seem
wrong
oh well such as the life we leave it
looks like chess comm came back for but
a second now it's gone I know he's
saying good go to lead chess but I can't
just switch these things on the fly here
can't just switch these things on the
fly this is a chess comp event so we are
here on chess calm
let's talk about funny moments in chess
history well I'll have you know I wrote
an article that featured one such funny
moment who here remembers the Twitter
feud it was called it wasn't really much
of a feud it was just a few
back-and-forth tweets between world
champion Magnus Carlsen and Dutch
champion Anish Garry who remembers this
who remembers this way back in 2018
during the candidates tournament Anish
Giri went on Twitter and said Magnus
Carlsen seemed a little bit nervous
about the potential challengers out of
the candidates and Magnus it's got a
little bit mad at them setup hey Giri
how about you win a tournament for the
first time in your life and then maybe
people will take you seriously that was
fun I miss those days back when people
play chess over the board
back when people play chess in person
now we just have these online matches
and we're so sad when the servers go
down so so sad
oh my god tesis what did he do I don't
understand these chat messages anymore
I've lost the thread where is Grand
Master Oh Cobian you're missing his
lectures he may be coming back near the
end of May maybe I cannot confirm nor
deny this things are in the works here
then Giri got him back by drawing all
his games he got that right here's a
good trash talker is a good trash talker
uh in the UH did you see the magnus
carlsen invitational when gary won his
first match against Magnus
he beat Magnus right who did he beat he
beat Magnus he did the he did this and
then he did one of these that's my
favorite celebration move what's what's
your guys's favorite celebration move
because I think Gary's little little arm
dance that's that's probably top five
top five and anybody's list the old uh
doo-doo-doo
any word on when the candidates
tournament will resume your guess is as
good as mine here your guess is as good
as mine hopefully when the world stops
ending that's when they'll get back to
the
the candidates I guess it's inner dot
tuck I was being sarcastic
ah you mean like spill the tea I'm
relevant
I'm current I spill some tea now and
again
so they're an a master I am a GM they
enjoy their games playing their games
over especially do I try to imitate
their style of play not in particular
not in particular I will say though
that's I will go through like the
database in opening lines that I play
and it turns out this guy named gosh
what is his name
there's some guy in the database and he
just plays all the same openings that I
do and I find myself like finding the
same lines that that he plays so I guess
that guy I want to say is I even Sokolov
but then it's like definitely not Ivan
Sokolov so maybe it's Ivan Sokolov I
have no idea what the guy looks like but
I just see his name in the database
because he plays all the stuff that I
play
I guess this little Q&A with Caleb isn't
isn't such a bad way to pass the time
hello Alan street Wars games here he's a
good trash talker my name is too weak
too slow
Magnus has some good quotes out there -
Magnus not a slacker in the
trash-talking Department himself not a
slacker who's my favorite chess player
um it might be Fabi I don't know I like
watching father's games he's fun to root
for fun to root for uh maybe Peters
fiddler I like Peters fiddler a lot so
glop seems to only play d4 rights and he
plays the f3 NIMS oh and he plays the
exchange qgb with f3 and he plays the
exchange Slav I think sometimes and then
he like played some opening I play with
black as well it's ridiculous isn't Gary
in last place yeah that sounds about
right
I think the only match he won was the
match against Carlsen which is kind of
funny yes good morning - English who
English - is the slit on the chess so if
you're just joining me here thanks to
the 53 of you for sticking this out with
me we are just sitting here refreshing
the chess comm page hoping against hope
that the server's return in time for the
match to resume here if they're not back
up by 710 unfortunately we're just going
to cancel the match is the official word
from Mike Magnus endgame edit I have not
seen the Magnus endgame edits Bobby is
fabulous and favi they got that right
hate to play against opponents play the
same openings as you your wines are
annoying yeah that's fair I'm like I
play some offbeat stuff against the
openings that I play I play a very very
strange line against the f3 NIMS Oh
where I go Knight f6 c6 Bishop b4 f3
castles oh ok
ok they took away my only fun they took
it away from me I hear I was making
making moves and now it's gone now it's
gone what if i refresh Brazil is
watching me somehow nice and still scary
ok like Knight f6 z 6 Bishop b4 f3 and
then I go ahead and castle a3 Bishop
takes B takes and then I play 98
achieving on move like 6 all of my
pieces on the back rank it's it's the
best way to play chess
have I I have met Vishy Anand this she's
a nice dude it's a nice dude did I have
a favorite chess book as a 1600 to 1800
player when I hit that reading range I
kind of slowed down on all the reading I
think um I consumed a lot of chest
content online um I really think a great
way to improve its back says oh gosh God
well you know to heck with anything I
was just saying is is it back
is it back it's gone it's not back I
consumed a lot of chest content online
nettie 8 with f5
I actually don't play for f5 so often
that five is more of a defensive
resource in that line and you can even
play f6 instead of f5 sometimes just to
block this diagonal and then the point
is you quite simply play Bishop a6
attacking see for a knight c6 Knight a5
attacking c4 c5 or xc8 open the C file
attack c4 and you just win upon on c4 in
exchange you went upon your opponent
gets to checkmate you so if that's the
type of chess you like playing you know
you get to win upon but then your
opponent checkmates you that's that's
the line for you
for some reason I like those positions
for some reason I quite like those
positions
yeah well in the Kings India but I'm
saying there are some differences there
are some differences
yeah the 98th line in the Kings ending
is actually pretty interesting well
there's like two main branches of the
Kings Indian right you step back with
the Knight to d7 or you step back to the
e8 in the classical line and with the
night on d7 the idea is you try to stop
c5 by controlling that square in ninety
eight kind of just allows c5 but it
protects the square that c5 is aimed at
attacking c5 is aimed at opening up the
C file in getting to c7 so 98 is already
preemptively defending that square so
it's an interesting idea both moves are
aimed at making c5 less effective ninety
seven just tries to prevent it ninety
eight guards against it it's some fun
it's some fun wait is it back his back
is back hold on a second hold on a
second it might be back it might be back
well then I'm not realizing I probably
need to change some things around here
cuz that ever so slightly just changes
the board up I think maybe it's going to
be fun okay Tracy is officially playing
a game see the thing about my line is
that yes it's about winning the c4 pawn
but really it's mostly about winning the
c-4 square if you get a piece to c4
you're feeling okay feeling okay what I
think of the Kia somehow I find it kind
of annoying to play against actually so
it's it's a little bit annoying for me
at least okay so yeah this does actually
mess some things up here so we're just
gonna make this super big super big
there you go oh and we're gonna need oh
my gosh oh it's well it's just way too
much
oh god it's taking over my face who who
designed this on chest comm who thought
that was a good idea oh my gosh I'm
gonna have to go way smaller here we go
here we go way smaller that's fine
who needs to see me anyways okay
too much down here even further making
adjustments on-the-fly oh there goes the
background that's not what I wanted
okay just like that we have adjusted the
stream craziness craziness here so we've
got two minutes to the start time and
the connection has been lost perfect
perfect exactly what I wanted what do I
think about the airsoft gambit is it one
of the aggressive openings I have heard
a very nasty rumor that the airsoft is
unbeatable so I mean it's hard to do
better than that
hard to do better than unbeatable
Erick's chess comm is not working he is
not alone in this oh it's back
oh it's back oh my gosh it's back isn't
here to stay
we'll see
it seems to be back but there does not
seem to be a match happening
unfortunately in progress it's the match
in progress don't think the match is in
progress think we missed the 7:10
deadline and it's it's done so here
think we're done zou
f 3 king up - King G 3 I don't know if
that is the way to go use the scoreboard
sighs it looks dirty it looks dirty okay
fair enough
I don't know what we're gonna do then I
guess we're just gonna fix we're gonna
switch the entire layout one more time
just we're having too much fun
changing the layouts what else are we
supposed to do you know
there you go oh I grab the background
again got a stop doing that it's really
like walking or something maybe the
smart thing do it's not even centered oh
my gosh I mean they're crazy I'm gonna
go crazy
trend Center everything now oh my gosh
oh my gosh all right well that's the
layout we are starting at round three
whoo all right so we've got 25 more
minutes to kill oh hey I'm good at
talking about nothing but I don't know
if I'm that good at that talking enough
talking about nothing
all right message retracted I think we
have we have abandoned that in that plan
makes me an interior designer maybe it
all falls under the Brig title of stream
operator
nice aspect is if you start losing you
can't blunder now I think that that
statement is not true
I have blundered many times when I was
losing oh boy now Liam leaves confused
oh my goodness
can I move pieces now if I flip to an
analysis board it seems as though I can
oh I accidentally played a Budapest this
is like the worst fate you could ever
wish upon somebody you guys know this
one it's a good chess game it's a good
chess game yeah that message was in fact
retracted so it is slightly unclear if
the match is going to happen at all do I
know any gambits in the caro-kann uh
I mean like every once in a while you
run into somebody
who how will they play they'll do
something like this but this is all just
just a little bit silly it's just good
for black just good for black you can
also be slightly strange can you be now
you really can I guess some if you want
to play like a game but for black you
could play like this I guess but I mean
it's it's all just a little bit silly
it's just giving up giving up pawns for
nothing it makes sense like the video
now well if you like what you're
watching do what you feel
yeah this is fine this is fine
man no no real main main gambits in the
karo I think well I guess there is you
can consider this a gambit for black b5
c5 and white can kind of keep this pawn
if white really wants to
okay I have confirmation from grant Owen
grant Owen seems to be a chest comm
staff member he is saying first two
rounds cancelled three minute games will
start in 22 minutes
assuming everything works out assuming
everything works out we shall see 7:35
p.m. all right boys 20 more minutes kill
20 more minutes what you guys want to do
all right should I just play some chess
should I just play some chess this was
the old guy with black hair I don't even
know who you're talking about old guy
with black hair not ringing any bells
here yeah it's the Blitz the black Mart
Deemer pretty much I don't know if it's
is it is it exactly the black Mart
Deemer I think it's just a black Mardy
Murie right it's all a little bit silly
it's all a little bit silly
okay but that's just the fantasy
variation I'd say that's just the
fantasy variation good ol Blackmar
Deemer all right fine I'll play a blitz
game I'm on my personal account but I
feel like you know these are pretty
extenuating circumstances so they can't
really get too mad at me
we'll see though got to fill this time
somehow so we're playing some 30-minute
see where we get in life oh gosh my
bishop somehow my pawn ended up on e6 I
wasn't paying attention wasn't paying
attention okay this turns bad this
turned bad can I take this or something
no that squares defended silly silly
stuff all right
h5 when in doubt right seems bad though
doesn't it seems really bad that's just
the fantasy variation okay that's just
the fantasy just a common line
so if you're just joining us we are of
course just feeling a little bit of time
here chest comm servers have been
undergoing some difficulties and now it
looks as though they seem to have
everything under control so we are just
hoping that it stays that way until it
is go time with this match this move
looks like check and then I don't know
what I'm gonna play but it's all getting
a little bit silly isn't it
it's starting to look very very silly
just in general
probably I should be losing this game f3
might just trap my queen
seems entirely possible I rigged up
three chaps my queen
okay he steps back I see well in times
of trouble it'll pull out the werid
moves we're going for him we're going
for him
seem to be losing a piece now instead of
my queen
things could be worse
I deserved worse first team to 128 and a
half all right I love it I love it
what a great score
okay I have two ponds two ponds for a
piece this one's probably gonna die
it might not though 93 could be a good
move
it's what I'm playing Bishop g5 just
come here take more pawns the goal is to
take enough pawns that it doesn't feel
like I'm losing quite so badly you know
at least make it seem like a fight night
f2 seems pretty good
I'm just gonna play Bishop g7 I'm not
super committed to taking on h3 I am
super committed to not letting his
Rickson and to checkmating me I get this
pawn now and I feel like I've won enough
pawns that doesn't feel like I'm getting
blown out of the water here so maybe
maybe life is okay maybe life's not so
bad especially after that move no okay I
thought just Bishop takes g3 there was
probably good enough for my opponent but
now I get to win and winnings fun see
look we win mmm
all right 16 minutes to go let's
officially start talking about this
let's start talking about this match
we're about to play so if you're just
joining us here in how many short
minutes 15 incredibly short minutes
shorter minutes than you would ever
believe we are going to be playing a
match against the Charlotte chess center
now the score to beat is going to be 128
and a half if we get to 128 and a half
total points then we will win the match
and just to keep you up on the format
here let me pull it up because we have
of course had some changes with all
these delays now the format is going to
be there are okay there are four rounds
of game in three minute where each
player plays the same opponent four
times so there's going to be kind of to
quote unquote chess comm matches that we
have with this game in three minute and
those are going to be worth double
points and then we will have another
portion of game in one minute and those
are going to be single weighted so the
score to be is 128 and a half so each
game in the game in three portion counts
for two and then we're gonna have these
one-minute games and hopefully by the
end of it our score totals at least 128
and a half so we have quite the roster
on our team actually the rosters for the
event if you're just joining for the
Charlotte chest center they have
grandmaster grandmaster daniel nerd it's
key heading the team of course Danya a
chess comm aficionado
I believe he's broken a few rating
records on this website
he's always in pretty heated contests
with a car playing some blitz and some
bullet we also have grandmaster Andrew
tank on the Charlotte chess center team
of course Andrew a Lee chess player has
just battled Magnus Carlsen earlier
today in fact Andrew one of the fastest
chess players in history especially
online we also have international master
Brandon Jacobson and feed a master Aaron
Jacobson on boards three and four for
the Charlotte chest Center these are two
brothers who play a lot of chess they've
been to st. Louis before and there are
some really talented chess players so be
on the lookout they also have feet a
master mark Plotkin who I believe I've
seen online before under little K
Plotkin or some name like this he plays
a lot of I believe bughouse leave he's a
buck house player now testing his mettle
in in regular chess here they also of
national master Chun Chiu Fung Wong
International Master
Carlos Perdomo Feeny master Robbie
Adamson national master Dominic Myers
and routing out their team is Vishnu
vana poly Carter Pete Minh Prada Yuma
Prada yuna probably I can't say it sorry
Coco poly Dominic Colombo who is yeah
and then Alex Velazquez PJ Leo Tino and
Andrew Chen so pretty impressive roster
for them
but then on our team we have them beat
I'm pretty sure we have to top 40 top 35
players in the world to 2700 plus
players in Grandmaster Liam Lee and
Grandmaster Jeffrey Zhang these are the
two players that head up our team truly
elite world-class players here we also
have international master Hans milk
Neiman who does some streaming himself
on Twitch you can check him out at I am
Hans Neiman we also have international
master Aaron grub in ski Webster student
on our team tonight's of course Aaron
recently getting this international
master title in the past year I think we
also have national master Gopal Menon
who also is streaming on Twitch with his
user name is professor daddy with an eye
we also have national master for Chen
national master Julian pearl a code
national master Nicholas Rosenthal
those are hopefully three names you're
coming to recognize now they have played
a lot of chess for the st. Louis chess
club team and they have done quite well
as well
Nick Rosenthal also starting up his own
twitch stream it's becoming a popular
thing these days his twitch username is
Froelich
67 67 it's F ro Li ke 67 67 we also have
Aditya pono kamati from the Wash U
University chess team Lukie on our team
as well
Eric tkachenko chess club employee over
two thousand these days on our team we
have a sushi panda a local chess kiddo
who has played in countless tournaments
here at the st. Louis chess club we also
have been Lou on our team Arjun the
famous Arjun for longtime viewers of the
YouTube lectures will definitely know
arjen's name he's the kid with all the
answers we also have video team leader
Jonathan's rants playing for us and
rounding out the team is Vinny toddy
party many another local player is in
our select chess program and has played
in countless matches
send a hug to your friend national
master belarius also known as fun
Pharrell okay I can try hug hug hug to
you
Hans is so anger sometimes Hans is an
interesting guy a quick story about Hans
for you I saw him at the u.s. amateur
team East event last year and the guy
had a pro chesley game scheduled later
in the morning and he still played the
morning round of the tournament he
realized he did the math that if he used
like less than 5 minutes on his clock in
the tournament game even if the opponent
used all of the time well then he could
he could make his pro chest League match
and so that's what he did and of course
he won and and then he he went and
played his protest League match and I'm
not sure how that went for him but the
guy is a little bit insane when does the
chest start well we have had some delays
Stephen board ah no the chest calm
servers actually went down for a long
long time so I've been feeling the time
a little bit but the match is now
hopefully officially going to start in 8
minutes and 38 seconds as of the moment
I said it so not too much longer to go
here watching from the shadows sounds
good
fortuitous fire sounds good I'm gonna
high-five work there you go high-five
high-five to everybody
now last match we had against the
Charlotte chess Center there it was a
very very close match actually I believe
the Charlotte chess Center edged it out
by a point by a single point
now that match was a part of a
round-robin event and thanks to our
scores in the other matches we actually
did end up on top of that round-robin
events and I believe I'm not sure how it
actually works against the Charlotte
chess center but there was one game
missing meaning one of the players from
one of the teams didn't join and so
maybe with some forfeitures we might
have one or maybe they won by more
points I'm not sure how it actually
happened but regardless it was an
incredibly close match and so this is
the grudge match to settle the score
here to find out once and for all
whose chess team is going to be the best
it's the st. Louis chess club or the
Charlotte chess Center who is going to
do it am i commentating i will be your
commentator for the night i keep trying
to get an invite to one of these matches
but my Kummer it just thinks i'm such a
such a great great commentator that you
know maybe I should stick to this
instead of trying to play chess which
fair enough I've stole this story before
but Christian trilha actually had me go
out and commentate on the Midwest
Collegiate Chess Championship that he
held last year and he said to me want
one of the days while that was going on
I said Caleb Europe you're a much better
commentator than you are a player and I
said huh well you're a much better coach
than you are a player and he took it as
a compliment
and well we'll say that's how I meant it
as well I will say that's how I meant it
okay six minutes to go here six and a
half minutes the round is going to start
and I guess tres is laughing at me
tres is always laughing at me it seems
like the chests calm servers have
stabilized so we are just waiting it for
this match to get going here just
waiting looks like both of our big
grandmasters are in the events the
chests calm format for this is like so
bad I can't even like see who these
players are oh well looks like we've got
both of our international masters as
well I'm counting one two three four
national masters that sounds just about
right for us right one two three four
yeah and then let's see one two three
four five six seven eight one two three
wait I can't count
oh my gosh okay and then we should have
eight other players let's see if that
count is correct as well we have one two
three four five six seven eight
okay looks like all of our players that
should be here are here
Charlotte seems to be missing some
people but it looks like our team has
worked through the connectivity issues
with the chest comm service and the team
is all ready to go on our end just five
more minutes why does it say sfv STL
originally this was just going to be one
match that we played and it was against
the san francisco mechanics and then we
blew them out of the water they didn't
stand a chance and we've been putting
together a few more matches now we're
doing one of these a week it seems like
I don't know if it's gonna keep being a
regular thing but we seem to be doing
about one every week and we just stuck
with the same club account for
simplicity's sake hello Jay Patel hello
hello Jay
can you survive six minutes of this for
a game of who knows what quality well
it'll be a game between Daniel nerd
Itsuki and Liam Lee top 35 chess player
in the world 2700 plus so it'll probably
be a pretty good quality and don't worry
if that game is bad we can always jump
over to Andrew tangs game against
Geoffrey Zhang where you know Geoffrey
Zhang is Geoffrey Zhang he never plays
bad chess what am i playing against the
fantasy in the caro-kann stay tuned
until next Monday night I believe that
is the line I'm going to be covering in
my lecture of chess openings explained
so if you're interested in the fantasy
variation stay tuned for that lecture
when my entire repertoire is going to be
revealed
also if you ever get paired with me in a
tournament just look up the same Louis
Chess Club YouTube video watch like 5
hours of lectures and you'll know
literally every line that I play hello -
Alan hello - Alan again citations oh
you're saying hello to ruwaida
well hello to row waiter Daniel is
strong Danya yes as I've said plays a
lot of internet chess
there's a lot of Internet chests
breaking chests calm reading records
crazy stuff am I going to move around no
next question
alright 2 minutes and 45 seconds to go I
have only been filling time for about 45
minutes now without anything to really
talk about so two minutes to go can we
make it another two minutes everybody
stick with me here stick with me
hopefully we'll get there hopefully
we'll get there what do I move first
normally I tend to move upon first I'm a
it 1.d4 kind of guy every once in a
while I'll mix it up and play it one of
these other mosts but normally one d4
sometimes I even play that move
sometimes I play that move it's crazy
you never tell what I'm gonna do
you can never tell what I'm gonna do can
I give you some puzzles in the mean time
the time for puzzles has passed J Patel
there's two minutes to go
there's two minutes to go here do you
want a puzzle a move ends with move
eight Knight takes h8 checkmate
construct the game there you go there's
a puzzle yes can do can do on your own
move eight Knight takes a CH a checkmate
I think I didn't even say the puzzle
correctly
it's probably like move six or something
but I can't remember it's one of those
retro retrograde analysis puzzles I
think I said that right start to count
down 127 one minute 26 minute 25 minute
24 in the 23 the vania I don't know the
vania
and is not one that I am familiar with
d4 is for the scared I'm gonna have to
disagree with you on that one
d4 is for people who like winning chess
games
it's for people like winning chess games
it was by kramnik I'm not sure if
Kramnik actually did that one
most of these fun retrograde analysis
ones there are a lot of fun if you
haven't heard of them before but most of
the famous ones are actually put out by
a chess base I think they do one like
every Christmas or do a series of them
every Christmas and there there are a
lot of fun some of them they just give
you a position and they tell you to
achieve it some of them they just like
tell you the final move of the game and
the move order and the move number
rather and you have to kind of construct
it it's it's good stuff Vania do you
mean that's not the Vinaya what is that
called why can't I remember what that's
called
seven seconds no time to figure out what
it's called the Vienna the Vienna okay
you're missing an N there Vienna
yeah the Vienna is pretty good it is not
too bad black can usually just play d5
tone and equalize okay this match should
be getting underway now should be
getting underwear and and what's this is
it a chess game oh my gosh it's a chess
game we're watching a chess game oh my
gosh
all right Lee Emily with the white
pieces here we're also gonna open up
penguin against Jeffrey X here looks
like Jeffery adopting Benoni approach
but let's stick with Liam Lee for this
first round here all right Liam Lee
controlling the center Danya taking a
modern approach as they say with the
quick fianchetto of the dark squared
bishop note that Danya has delayed
playing Knight f6 it makes you wonder if
he's going to go for a quick f5 that's
generally what it means when these
players are delaying playing this move
Knight f6 it means they want to play f5
really early on you can sometimes even
yeah I didn't mean to draw an arrow
tonight h6 but sometimes you can even
play a move like night h6 now though
simply Knight f6 with D takes e5 f5
becomes a lot less natural for for for
black so Knight f6 instead finally and
now which way will white go white will
go Kings side and this is just the type
of position now where white has a little
bit of extra central space black is
going to be looking to break free with a
move like d5 white is going to look to
restrict the black pieces and make use
of this Bishop pair one move that
springs to mind is a move like Knight g4
trying to get rid of this bishop but I
imagine this bishop could just simply
move out of the way to a square like f4
and nothing has really been achieved so
what is black going to do here
maybe Queen e7 York d8 it doesn't seem
good enough there's some pressure on the
Queen side so Queenie 7 is danya's move
but the problem of trying to get d5 in
is is not going to be so easy
in fact I don't think black is even
going to try at this point because d5 is
coming with with too many problems now I
quite like Liam Lee's position here I
think it's gonna be a good one so a6 is
perhaps preparing rook d8 by removing
this pawn from the threat of capture
also keeps an eye on this B 5 square so
that night b5 or Bishop b5 is never
going to come any nasty threats white
might play a move like f3 so white plays
h3 instead okay now b5 by black is
looking for a c4 square white was
perhaps looking to play the move f4 to
kick this Knight out of its nice outpost
on e5 so b5 kind of plays against this
f4 idea by giving the knight the c-4
square I wouldn't be surprised to see
the move b3 from white here but now just
f4 if Knight c4 I definitely expect to
see if Bishop takes c4 now so Liam Lee
decides he's fine giving up this bishop
on c4 in order to bring this pawn up to
c4 and when black is going to just have
quite a number of weaknesses to to look
out for
so with b5 on the board I imagine Danya
is going to go here no so b4 is a nice
little Intermezzo and now we go into
very forcing line black had to take this
night and now I guess
Liam Lee is deciding between pawn takes
or Queen takes here really either one
seems reasonable pawn takes this Knight
has to go to d7 now and then I imagine
this bishop is going to move to a square
like g4 maybe even the simple f3 could
be could be considered here or perhaps
even bishop f2 just yet bishop f2 is is
the cleanest and now you're just
threatening discoveries here black
pieces are slightly awkward okay we have
Queen f6 now Bishop d4 is it potentially
a good move hitting this Queen oh I
guess there's just trades what am I
saying what am I saying
just traits ok b4 is hanging but b2 is
also hanging
so Liam Lee does take I imagine Tania
will take me to in some order
so rook b8 is preparing to take it with
the rook but now Queen a four hits this
night and it's not so clear what this
Knight is doing is they coming to b6 is
it coming to c5 it's like coming back to
f8 because a6 is going to hang as well
black is getting activity on this B file
here on b2 but is it going to be enough
for this this pawn will black end up
regaining the pawn I'm not so sure the
move Bishop takes b6 looking incredibly
unnatural but perhaps it's worth
considering here yeah okay so he doesn't
do it it's too unnatural but the point
being you would have to take back with
the with the pawn if you took back with
the rook then their work here hangs just
to kind of mess up the structure but da
not enough to give up this great Bishop
for white this Bishop defends a lot of
squares around the King and so it's
definitely one white wants to keep
around Bishop f3 now the c2 pawn is
hanging moves like rook c1 might be
considerable then for White's trying to
get into c7 so we see a take a trade on
a one instead now Bishop d4 and okay
what's going on here Queen back to e2
takes takes and now material is even
white is left with a bishop against the
night this night isn't actually leaving
the best impression over here on b6 and
pressures d5 but it's a little bit out
of play and now lammle is going to look
to find threats on this Kings side in
order to counteract this this Queen on
the Queen side so now Liam Lee picks up
the c7 pawn in return
Danya gets the f5 pawn okay scary checks
but Queen g3 covers the rook as well and
we are nearing what seems to be an equal
endgame lammle just a little bit down on
the clock here it is three plus so
there's no increment so be on the
lookout you can't push because the pawn
isn't defended okay gotta go fast freely
Emily
Danya of course a very fast internet
player very fast online okay perhaps he
was looking for Queen e5 there it didn't
find it
c5 now it just takes okay so Liam Lee
just gets rid of this pawn that's a
knight
that's the night okay gotta go four
flags now gotta go four flags gotta go
fast gotta go fast okay and Oh big news
Jeffrey Zhang actually already won the
first game against penguin so the score
now is three to five in this first match
note that these matches are actually
double weighted so each of these points
counts for two so it's really crucial
that we do well here in the three-minute
portion
why don't we keep an eye on Jeffrey
Zhang's second game now see what he can
do against penguin see if he can make it
to and OH
what was this opening I'm not even sure
what has happened here looks like maybe
some e45 business the Royal apes' type
of stuff with a bishop exchange on c6 so
Jeffrey now with a big Center is looking
to put some pressure on these bishops on
this bishops parrot trying to take away
some diagonals and use the central space
to his advantage he's got some pressure
on this F pawn as well and it's all
about making sure these Knights are
serving useful purposes here see five
challenges the center the move d5 comes
to mind hitting this bishop now the
trick to playing against the bishops is
always to keep diagonals closed you want
to close off diagonals wherever possible
to prevent these bishops from being too
strong ninety-five seems like a good
move Bishop g4 could be following enough
Queen f2 well then Knight g4 Oh but then
Bishop c5 okay so the internet shows a
kind of compound here and perhaps this
was missed by Andrew tang now this
Bishop is hanging and this pawn is
hanging how do you save both I'm not so
sure tonight g4 Bishop takes pawn okay
Knight takes F - Bishop takes Queen and
what's going on Knight takes e4 96 f2
Knight takes or 90 X up to Bishop Dixie
7 Knight takes e4 maybe ok no he just
takes back here ok and takes on d5 so
what's going on material is actually
equal and black managed to trade off a
knight for a bishop so I think Andrew
got the better end of this this kind of
exchange here this this weird Intermezzo
desperado type of type of exchange I
think went in Andrews favor okay so a
two is hanging efore is under pressure
and none of these Knights make any sense
I really dislike whites whites position
here okay so he's unpinning now at the
very least and now how do you deal with
this e4 pawn in the long run I'm not so
sure Jeffrey's trying to organize the
pieces okay h5 is looking for age for a
kick this night away c3 is a nice move
like I said you want to close off
diagonals as much as possible
but really the position just continues
to open up here regardless of what jefra
tries to do
he's now sacrificing this efore pawn if
Andrew wants to take it he's gonna have
to give up a bishop and in return
Jeffery might find some activity at
least with these rooks on d7 but
regardless looking pretty rough for for
Jeffery here now if Bishop takes it is
just going to be a full pawn sacrifice
Andrew wants to keep the bishops on the
board though wants to keep the bishops
on the board okay and what's this it
looks like Andrew missed a tactic just
missed a tactic here this is a
significant improvement to Geoffrey
zhang's position with the LightSquared
Bishop off the board one night versus
one Misha is much more manageable than
two knights against two bishops this
structure kind of compensates for the
lack of the pawn of course penguin is up
upon here up an extra double death pawn
but Jeffrey's position I think should be
okay it's a little bit awkward to deal
with these threats as well as rook e1
threats so b5 is now looking for c4
Andrew of course doesn't allow c4 to
come on the board it's just difficult to
keep this rook from invading to all of
these squares and it looks like Andrew
is actually going for some mating ideas
with with this type of structure
Jeffrey's kind of relegated to just
shuffling back and forth now okay this
allows Ricky 1 though this allows Ricky
1 in 90 to Ricky 3 and what's what's
happening
okay gives up this pawn but it's
with the king that's the type of
maneuver that only Jeffrey Zhang would
would play that's the type of stuff that
requires such accurate calculation you
know to see that the discoveries on e3
aren't going to be super impactful
that's that's kind of crazy either that
or he got lucky one of the two now the
time is going to be the relevant factor
here and I think Jeffrey Zhang is going
to win this game
I really think Jeffrey's going to win
this is kind of absurd if King g3 there
is Knight f5 with a fork okay Jeffrey
now takes off in H pawn and he has all
the winning chances and he's up on time
this move is check and Wow he's just
winning now this is just winning on the
board takes here and this game is over
this game is over
great job - Jeffrey song unfortunately
Liam Lee also lost his second game - to
what's-his-face
- Danya okay looking at the next highest
board here we have looks like who is
this I don't know the chest comm names
we have Gopal menon here on our team
against a little Plotkin little Plotkin
it looks like this game has gone poorly
for us so let's jump back here find a
better game to look at it's not gonna be
that game it looks like the lower boards
are where we need to shine who is this
Julian Pro like Oh lost his first round
is hoping to not lose the second one
unfortunately it looks like f7 is
hanging and there's not gonna be a good
way to defend that so hoping to find
solace in the bishops of opposite colors
now is Julian rook d7 Bishop c5 this
past pawn is going to be difficult to
stop unfortunately in fact this is
starting to look like checkmate
starting to look a lot like checkmate
you have to play g5 now and this is a
little bit too much I think
rook c7 yeah this is this is looking
dead looking a little bit dead now
hey bishop f8 there's there's a check
and to take oh but now the bishop hangs
the bishop banks okay maybe it's not
totally totally busted in fact is Julian
winning a pawn back now no he's not it
he might be Julie might be saving this
game believe it or not oh he gives up
this punch for no reason though rook
takes h4 would have kept that pawn
defended okay it's going to come down to
a time scramble as these games often do
in the meantime the match score is 14 to
13 in our favor okay
rooks come off the board this should be
a loss now for black but 12 seconds or
13 seconds isn't enough going to have to
be a fast play no it's a it's a draw
it's just a draw he shuffles and then it
should be just dead drawn I think got a
shuffle faster Julian got a shuffle
faster it looks like he's actually
lagging a bit got it out of shuffle
faster yeah going to lose this one on
time and that's a loss for us
unfortunately I don't think that
position actually was drawn I think I
made that up so Julian goes down - oh it
looks like the final score we come out
on top
just barely 17 - fifteen important stuff
here and it looks like yeah Jonathan
actually managed to win his second game
as well we had a lot of splits here it
looks like Eric went one and a half out
of two for us that was big
it looks like Jonathan went to a no
actually Jonathan with two big points
for us that was critical and then we
cleaned up on the middle boards actually
the middle boards are where we cleaned
up with it looks like honestly these
names are not readable these names are
not readable chess comm okay bug in the
studio but if you're not it looks like
yet Nick Rosenthal went to an O for us
and it looks like blitz master who is
blitz master I should know who blitz
master is let me check of course that is
not our I am sketchy moves that's Aaron
gurbin ski going to a no for us as well
crucial stuff here crucial stuff other
to know of course Jeffrey is Zhang okay
up next we have match number four
starting in just over a minute and it
looks like we're missing a player we're
missing a player who are we missing
we've got one minute to get in here one
minute to get in okay it looks like
everybody's in now looks like
everybody's in just in time
50 seconds till the neck next match
starts there is not a lot of downtime
between these matches I have to tell you
so it is 30 for 30 of course these
matches are double weighted in three
minute matches double weighted his
opponent homeo Queen and flecked sounds
like a game Jonathan trance a play
sounds like a game Jonathan would play
most of that pre moves turned off it
looked like he was having some
connectivity issues I was seeing just a
little bit of lag
oh my gosh okay ten more seconds of me
resting my voice and then it'll be back
to that kind of rapid-fire commentary
that hopefully makes some amount of
sense although I have my doubts
okay and we are underway waiting for the
games to load in now who is this this
person shouldn't be in the match oh
that's Brandon Jacobson Brandon Jacobson
should be in the match okay breaking
news here due to these matches being
rated rain and Jacobson's rating has
actually surpassed that of Andrew tang
so Brandon Jacobson new board two for
the Schroth of chess Center all right
that's crazy stuff and we have now that
checkmate that I showed while we were
waiting for the tech difficulties to
sort out we have a Budapest by Brandon
Jacobson and let's see how Jeffery can
dismantle the Budapest in my experience
he's actually playing the line that I
play it's all about playing this move c5
when Mike gets this move c5 in black is
going to be in some danger so that's why
we see b6 now holding on to the c5
squared even b4 is a consideration now
for white to really push this idea
through in the meantime look to see
black trying to play on the Kings side
so B 497 even further defends this c5
square it's all about c5 for white rook
d1 now puts more pressure on this D file
really just trying to get c5 through
that's the key break here for white
thank you for joining us Alan thank you
for joining okay yeah c5 now takes takes
takes I imagine has to be played what
else can be played okay and the idea for
Jeffery was Bishop b5 as a nice
Intermezzo now with this night being
pinched I yes C takes b4 is going to be
not quite accurate due to this move rook
takes c7 and out of nowhere water
appears thank goodness that I was
struggling here I was struggling
see takes before rook c7 is Jeffrey's
Young's idea and this seems like a
powerful idea now I expect to see a
simple takes on c5 I don't know what
Queen e6 was actually achieving yeah it
simply takes on c5 and now things are
collapsing for black player here maybe
c6 is what he wants but it's just not
going to work Queen takes d6 in response
to c6 so how do you solve these problems
okay and we have an exchange sacrifice
this was Brandon Jacobson's idea but
this cannot be good for black I think
Geoffrey and simply achieved a winning
position the move Queen a5 comes to mind
hitting all of the weaknesses in the
black camp the downside of course is you
don't want to leave your king too
unattended here that is the way that's
Brandon Jacobson is going to get back
into the game if you just kind of forget
about your Kings side so rugby one
instead keeping this clean on the second
rank where it could or it can actually
be a very useful to fender
so between g4 is the obvious move that
everybody saw coming bishop g3 to guard
against the mate age 4 now Brandon
Jacobson has an idea and he's sticking
to it
so f3 allows Bishop takes f3 what's the
idea no it doesn't okay we broke this
pin of course obviously excuse me okay
now Eve for challenging the d5 square
and it looks like Geoffrey is simply
consolidating here now you can actually
really start considering moves like
Queen a5 to just bust open the entirety
of this Queen side maybe rook d2 Eirik
b2 is a simple move but no Queen a5 you
can play rook d2 later if you need to
guard the second-ranked Geoffrey decides
his king is safe enough and now he's
going pawn hunting going on a pawn hunts
going on a pawn hunt 96
like I said Brandon just totally
rerouting to this Kings side now it's
it's pretty much checkmate or bust at
this point for Brandon Jacobsen rook b8
is a really nice move the point is you
can take this a pawn whenever you want
it what you can't do is protect your
King later if you don't protect it now
rook b8 pins this Bishop to this rook
starts getting some more pieces off the
board starts getting closer to the type
of endgame that is just going to be
totally dead I trust Geoffrey Zhang to
win this game let's check in on lammle
up against Dan Danya once again this
seems to be a pretty reasonable position
I think I keep thinking these rooks are
doubled but there's a jeep on in the way
it's looking very very odd for Danya odd
but is it bad I'm not so sure I think
okay and now I've counted the pawns
White's up upon blacks King is unsafe
and black doesn't seem to have
compensation for it there's like some
some cheap threats against g2 but Liam
Lee should just be doing very well here
that's our brief check-in back to
Geoffrey's long johns game looks like
Bishop d7 ended up being played and we
do see one set of rooks come off the
board every pair of pieces that gets
traded off gets Geoffrey closer to just
a technically winning endgame that's the
goal here
c5 is nice this pawn is pinned and
Brandon Jacobsen is out of time this
move is coming now
he takes D difficult to stop in fact
impossible to stop and Geoffrey Zhang
wins his first game I'm calling it
unfortunately on the other board
Hans Neiman has actually fallen to
penguin in their first match and they
have started a second one now Geoffrey
Chong did in fact when that one let's
check in on Hans see how he's doing here
looks like they played very very quickly
in this game and not so good for Hans no
wait good for Hans not so good for Hans
not so good at all bad for Hans not good
at all no no no goodbye okay this game
has gone into a time scramble now this
move is check this move is okay that
move is is check this move is defending
Kim G to now okay Bishop f6 is nonsense
but it's it's fine
and they're pre moving and back and
checkmate okay get that off the board
get these pawns off the board and and
checkmate
Liam Lee goes down Liam Lee had black oh
my gosh I got the colors wrong in that
game I really thought Liam Lee had white
okay well that's a win for Danya they're
unfortunate really thought
Liam Lee had
white pieces in that game Wow okay what
a turnaround in Game two
let's watch jeffrey zhang again he has
the black pieces here fool me once shame
on you fool me twice shame on me
okay and this position looks slightly
less comfortable there's this pressure
on v6 that jeffrey has to be aware of if
the bishop ever lands here it's gonna be
kind of devastating why it's looking to
expand now on the queenside
looking to get this night out of the way
perhaps and expanded with a move like c4
in the meantime Jeffrey's position is is
very cagey
it looks like he's rerouting this Bishop
out to g7 here but if you do so then d6
is going to be quite weak it's honestly
not so easy for me to find out how
Jeffrey's going to break free here
what if d5 immediately this might be
what's being calculated right now the
immediate d5 with the idea of taking on
b4 Jeffrey doesn't go for it but it
looked kind of interesting
so Ricky 6 defends over here now if F 5
gets played what's happening what's
happening after f5 rookie 5 I guess is
is fine I mean well takes takes an in
rook yeah f5 does happen in rookie 5 is
is his choice
maybe now g5 has to come I'm not so
happy ok d5 though d5 Jeffery breaks
free this is the nice idea that I was
looking for Jeffery to play going after
this b4 upon the move before from white
just seemed a little bit a little bit
unnecessary it really weakens a lot of
squares over here including the pawn
itself and Jeffrey's looking to take
advantage of it the move Bishop d4
though might be a potential problem here
so we do see this exchange now of b4 4 D
5 and after g6 Jeffery goes up upon with
Queen takes a5 up upon ends with perhaps
a a winning position rights c3 looks
difficult to fence
I suppose Bishop d4 has to be the move
ok inserts this move now Knight takes
though and both of these pieces are
hanging I don't think route takes e5 was
was quite accurate I think Bishop d4 had
to be played in fact Brandon Jacobsen
just resigns
Hans has somehow drawn this game he
flagged him he flagged him hans flagged
the penguin hans flagged them incredible
incredible flag from Hans Neiman saving
that half point
so Brandon Jacobsen going down to out to
Jeffrey's young Jeffrey so far has been
killing it with a perfect for no record
let's check back in now on Liam Lee in
his fourth game against Daniel nerd it's
key
Liam Lee so far unable to take outs to
take out
Danya what's happening now though Queen
III can i count the pieces one two three
one two what am I missing where's the
tactic where's the big tactic at I don't
understand how what's ok I don't
understand is Liam Lee just up a piece
here there's some some threats for for
black to be sure but but a piece is a
piece is a piece Rick see one now Rick
see one must be the move to kind of
evict this Queen okay Bishop e2 instead
okay Bishop b2 makes a lot of sense I
can get behind Bishop e2 I'm happy with
that move
I'm happy with that move
okay this move threatens the night f-for
it's somehow defends it ie five now is
is the crazy move by Danya I think we
can just take this though we have to
just take this okay and no d5 keeps the
diagonal closed keeps this past pollen
on the board d5 is a pretty nice move
okay now it's gotta be York c1 no Queen
B - okay note that this Bishop opening
up was the whole point of Donna's play
there over the past few moves I imagine
d6 now might be the move rook d1 is
preparing such such pawn pushes in fact
yeah d6 and the problem now I guess is
rook c3 Brooks III is is dawnia's idea
maybe night c5 okay 94 instead similar
idea just removing this Knight from all
these threats of capture and now works
III has in fact been stopped with this
blockading night okay now knight c6
comes to mind in 96 rook c3 okay and
what's the point
Queen f4 okay Queen takes e4 even this
this rook is hanging this trade is
threatens Liam Lee's up a piece
Liam Lee is just up a piece looks like
Liam Lee is just up a piece here
the result is wrong do you mean the
result is wrong
Hans should get a win it's not a drop it
is in fact a draw under the chest calm
rules
Chester calm does not use the feed a
rules for insufficient material it's not
if checkmate is legal it's if you have
mating material quote unquote so if you
have at least a night in a bishop or two
bishops or things of that nature
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh no oh no oh no
oh no Liam Lee oh no oh no ninety-seven
oh no oh no 95 but oh no no Emily why
why did you hang your ugly Emily I can't
look anymore
I can't look let's watch every group in
ski win okay Aaron Gerber in ski with
the white pieces here believe it or not
this King is not where it should be and
so Aaron gourbin skis going to win as
angry Minsky often does what's going on
here check me okay Eric Kaminsky wins
this one Liam Lee goes down
unfortunately all right let's check in
here now on global with the black pieces
here so let's go ahead flip the board
see how he's doing he looks like he got
a draw in his third game here I think he
went oh and two against Plotkin in the
first match so drop probably a good
result but now okay now it's just it's
it's what it always is in three minute
isn't it it's it's what it always ends
up being checks that that move is check
that move is checked play it play the
check you got the check you got to check
the guy okay here just he's so slow he's
so slow you got to go faster than this
got to go faster and somehow Plotkin
found the mate I can found the mate okay
in the meantime what do we have here
this game still going on this is Nick
Rosenthal trying to flag in this game
and he does these big flags save
the match for us and we went again 16
and a half to 15 and a half so we take a
lead at the end of the three-minute
portion here we definitely take a very
significant lead now I have to click on
the next tournament before it starts
without me and that concludes the
three-minute portion that concludes the
three-minute portion here now all that's
left are one-minute bullet games all
right we had 34 to 30 in the first match
and then that score I think we just had
33 to 31 so we are up to 67 points to
play my account it looks like we all
agree in the chat so we are over the
halfway mark for that 128 magic number
128 and a half to win it all as expected
it's shaping out to be a pretty close
match here and it's going to come down
now to the bullet portion Geoffrey Zhang
of course a phenomenal player and any
time control in chess but I feel like
now Andrew tang is really going to start
to shine for the for the Charlotte chess
center Andrew Tang a phenomenal
world-class bullet player against
anybody really so we shall see what goes
on here who is this FM who is 29.95 for
the Charlotte chess Center I'm gonna
have to watch this game which FM is this
is this Aaron Jacobson with the crazy
rating it's FM one random is that Aaron
Jacobson let us let us find out let us
find out that is Aaron Jacobson so Aaron
Jacobson faces Liam Leigh here crazy an
FM with a 3000 bullet reading that is
terrifying that guy must be so fast
let's keep an eye though on Geoffrey
Zhang against Danya Jeffery with the
black pieces here we missed the opening
I could not tell you what opening it was
looks like the D pawns got traded
somehow okay now Bishop a3 put some
pressure on this night I expect a rookie
eight will follow soon there's just some
some loose dark squares now around the
black King okay this pawn is hanging but
Jeffery counter-attacks this night
instead we see a trade of the Queens
was Jeffrey going to deal with this
problem just okay no Eve fourth that's a
much better way this is a free pawn this
is a free pawn if he wants it
free pawn if you want it Jeffrey free
pawn if you want it he does want it
he takes it rook d2 is coming now rook
d2 is coming like a rook t1 instead 96
Jeffrey Zhang just up a pawn here rook
d8 defends the night in Knight f5 King
King f8 King yeah okay high level
players get their kings into the center
for the endgame okay Geoffrey and just
maneuvering with this night now stuff
like Knight f3 is going to come you can
even just take this fish up off the
board and now this King is going to be a
little bit weak in this end game with
this f3 pawn and so Danya goes to trade
off the rooks but ends up keeping them
on anyways
pawn takes now and this is an opposite
color Bishop endgame but it is one that
is just winning c5 shakes loosen this
Bishop and Geoffrey now up a piece now
up a rook 18 seconds to win and Danya
resigns checking back in on Liam lead in
the time scramble down a piece against
FM Aaron Jacobsen okay but you know it's
bullet anything can happen
I imagine moving like Bishop f1 now
Queens see one might come anyways okay
there's a check and back guarding Bishop
c4 got a guard Bishop c4 here maybe more
checks okay more checks now okay Bishop
c4 was was playable maybe it should've
been played Bishop c4 playable again ah
it wasn't playable he's been tricked and
now oh gosh now it's now it's just down
to speed and I think I think any FM with
the 3000 bullet reading speed is 3000
bullet reading is going to be
superhumanly fast that's that's how you
get that kind of rating okay back to
Geoffrey Jean oh my gosh what's
happening there's a knight on d3 and
apana need to okay this looks like an
exchange sacrifice okay Geoffrey Jean
going down the exchange early on on
purpose you know your guess is as good
as mine this Knight has to go to b5 now
e to false and yeah life is bad life is
bad for Geoffrey Jean here life is not
life is not good it's not what you want
out of life okay
c4 I guess Knight f4 is coming life is
life is not good life is not good he's
trying to find some threats over here
wait what was that move okay it was 494
Queen and he's going for checkmates but
it looks ok he's going for what what
what is happening what is happening ok
no wait
this is interfered with ok what is
happening
does anybody know what's happening I
don't understand what's happening
ok he's guarding against promotion
what's the material counts does anybody
know what's happening ok Queen d2 and
yeah justjust resigns it couldn't
couldn't be right for Geoffrey there's
so Danya comes back and wins via the
second match there and it looks like
we've just gotten destroyed so far in
this matchup
okay back to Liam Lee's game let's see
how Liam Lee is doing here with the
black pieces
and okay Liam Lee seems to be hanging a
Jeep on now Queen B - on the board
Bishop takes c3 is the threat will it be
played or F for but this is just this
was the point right
okay no not Bishop takes a a seven
getting played we have some trades now
and I'm now realizing that Liam Liam to
have fewer pieces on the board than his
opponent not a good sign for Liam Lee
having fewer pieces on the board that
move his check then move his check and
move his check I move his check okay all
right
that's sad I don't want to see any more
make it go away make it go away oh gosh
make it go away all right let's see how
Gopal is doing looks like not well oh
gosh we got destroyed in the first
bullet match okay we just got destroyed
in the first bullet match that's fine
though that's fine we'll come back
stronger than ever in the next one we
will come back stronger and we will come
back stronger okay that should bring the
score to 75 and a half for us to 83 and
a half for them that's not so good
what's wrong with Liam I don't know he
just does not seem to be getting it done
does not seem to be getting it done okay
one minute to the next match up here
we're missing two players inserts in
nine seconds oh my gosh you got to get
in you got to join the match you got to
join the match oh my gosh they're not in
the match oh no oh no we're missing two
players oh my gosh ah okay Geoffrey Jean
once again playing against Tania once
again we need Geoffrey to do well this
looks like a threat what happens what
happened Jeffrey Jeffrey Jeffrey what's
going on Jeffrey don't do this to me
what's gone Oh Oh No ah
there should be three Queen a4 check
what is this
Geoffrey no it's so bad oh it's so bad
oh gosh it's just so bad I can't look
anymore
I can't look anymore lammle lammle will
win a chess game oh my gosh what is this
position
Liam Lee why is your king on c6 what is
happening what is going on these are the
strangest chess positions I've ever seen
in my life there's a king on c6 there's
no pawns what how did this happen I need
to see how this happened okay there was
a sacrifice and now the Knights on E
eights like what is happening here g3
rook d4 now is hoping to trade okay that
move is check and this ruckus hanging
but this Knight is hanging and it's just
a mess it looks like Liam Lee might be
consolidating with two bishops for a
rook but is he also checkmated and like
also it's a bullet game by the way look
out for your clock Queen g7 Queen see it
instead okay maybe Bishop you just got
it you got to get these pieces out
somehow you got these pieces in the game
okay takes Bishop h6 now I like Bishop
h6 Queen c7 comes on the board okay and
the bishop Falls and now it's the time
scramble and I don't think Liam Lee is
going to win this time scramble
unfortunately
where's position less time and I think
Erinn is just a faster player okay
Geoffrey is still in this game no
Geoffrey lost round one this is a new
game this is a new game and this
position looks a lot more okay for
Geoffrey
it's a lot more okay for Jeffrey okay
the score though is ten to six we seem
to be doing well on these lower boards
that's where it really counts
you know it's well and good to have Dan
learned it's key win every game but it
doesn't or Erin Jacobsen win every game
but it doesn't oh my gosh Jeffrey why
why you can't do this to me you can't do
this to me all right Liam Lee will win
Liam Lee will win he has to win nobody
for OHS Liam Lee nobody for OHS this guy
just doesn't happen Bishop g4 h3 now
okay Queen c2 and this is a chess
position
finally a chess position that I can see
and comprehend okay this is Bishop yeah
okay you got to move this Queen out of
the way it's a chess position
Liam Lee is playing chess that means he
has good chances to to win the game you
know these nonsense positions I I trust
Aaron Jacobsen to win but chess games
that's where Liam Lee is good he's a
chess player and look at him picking up
an extra pawn on the Queen side okay
with the extra pawn life is good life is
very good for Liam Lee now rook c7 is
nice Bishop c4 is coming Bishop c4 check
get the shrimp c-4 check at some point
oh gosh now Bishop c4 check what are you
doing maybe even rook takes rook takes
this is nasty this is nasty Bishop takes
here this rook is still hanging
oh that's just checkmate okay Liam Lee
coming back finally with a win
Liam Lee with a win that's all you have
to do Liam Lee you just have to play
chess okay I don't know what he was
playing before but it was very much not
chess okay and Hans gets flagged
unfortunate unfortunate okay and what's
going on here it looks like no time okay
no time there and down on this board
what's going on okay it looks like a
murder castle whose fortune is taking on
little Plotkin here and that was there
so fast oh my gosh dropped by
insufficient material Oh
there is just so so fast that was so
scary
okay and here we have Nick Rosenthal
taking on IM capital and it's a draw
okay is there another one going on well
wait a second what is this okay we won
that one barely by a point but then
they're what they're playing another
game or something what's happening what
what oh this one already started this
one started before the last one finished
missus this is so silly
this is so so silly okay things are
falling apart here not only knows what's
happening anymore
the next match started before the first
match I did I think we need to work on
the format of these a little bit it's
getting a little bit too a little bit
too wild all right so this one does not
seem to have all the players in it
because it started before the previous
one ended so we're just gonna follow
Liam Lee and don't ask me what's going
on with the scoring system now because
there's only like one two three four
five six there's only like nine players
in this one there's only like nine
players okay it looks like though Liam
Lee is up upon and it's a chess position
thank God Liam Lee has a chess position
that's all he has to do and then he can
win he can't win these positions that
are nonsense but he can win chess
positions okay Bishop takes a for king
f2 now if Bishop takes h3 there was a
knight C - I think - uh - grab that
night and now King F - Liam has given up
his extra pawn but this should be a very
very good end game for white in fact I
think it should just be winning yay he
pushes on the on the Kings side this is
a great past pawn over here and it's
going to be very tough to practically
hold this for for Aaron okay even g6 now
yeah okay
this controls the queening square now
king of six and up black has to
sacrifice the bishop the King comes back
into play and just don't give away all
the pawns and you'll be fine here okay
Liam Lee holding on
oh my gosh she lost on time he lost on
time I can't believe it he can't believe
it I can't believe it nobody can believe
it depends I mean doesn't like the
format either fair enough
yeah I mean thank god he's playing chess
positions though that's that's really
that's the key here
um all right we'll see if Liam Lee can
take down Aaron in this one as well
night a three all right what's going on
looks like a chess position again
all right I'm happy chess positions good
Bishop a5 yeah nice if Knight B 496 oh
but then a3 so yeah night before played
and so just Bishop f5 he just lets this
Knight sit on this awkward be Foursquare
no no there's not a knight on the planet
that wants to sit on the be for square
that is not an outpost so now we have
this Bishop on e4 tonight's kind of just
floating here it is attacking d5 but it
is it's it's kind of just floating it's
a bit of a weird piece okay maybe yeah
so takes in rook c2 now nice the rook
gets into the game Queen out to f6
expect to see Liam Lee to double here on
the C file and life is is good life is
good d4 is under pressure Queen b6 keeps
up the pressure into tax b4 now rook c4
doubles this pressure f6 now and d4
false and d4 false that move is checked
so there was no Bishop e3 okay rook e3
is fine just Queen c6 now
okay this move attacks a rook I don't
see why but sure Queen c6 okay why are
we not playing Queen c6 I'm so confused
okay weird takes and Bishop okay just go
fast Liam just go fast
where on earth I in it I don't know Mike
comer wants me to commentate so i
commentate i trust
mike's judgment put together the winning
team okay opposite color bishops now but
uh should should be a win yeah queen bee
one even you can trade and play a five
orders play five first that's even
better
I mean B three now okay we see a trade
and this Bishop comes here and big
blockade now for Aaron what's happening
oh my gosh just push the pawn just make
a quick just make a queen just make a
queen take Queen oh my gosh dude do not
lose this game on time okay is two and a
half seconds left for some reason I
thought he only had like point two
seconds left me at two and a half left
okay well we somehow one this one eleven
and a half to four and a half I have no
idea if that's even true next one in
less than a minute 3 seconds to join you
join in a second alright the gun in
there somehow hopefully I don't know
geez
they need a little bit more break time
in between these matches this is just
this is too too much this is too much
okay this one now in progress we have
Geoffrey Zhang back against Daniel nerd
its key all rights before takes takes
okay Geoffrey's got a chest position
that's good we're good at chess
positions with chess players bug in the
studio alright a lot of pressure on
these pawns I really actually do prefer
Geoffrey's position here I like this
side of the quote unquote hanging pawn
structure where you're the one
pressuring these pawns with slightly
less space but you know tangible
weaknesses those are great things to
have in chess games things that you can
attack like the pawn on c5 Queen b5 is a
very strange move rook b8 makes sense
now b4 and and Geoffrey's pushing
forward Queen b5 makes a lot of sense
it's c4 or hits d3 rather but maybe
Queen c4 Knight f8 is this choice is
coming up to e6 now g5 hits this
pawn don't lose okay c5 defense
laterally not be three on the board okay
rook takes d3 zap on vertex t3 s upon 96
is probably coming Knight be Queen b5
maybe Knight takes e5 is getting a
little bit strange takes and rook e8 but
then Knight f6 is coming Knight f6 no
Knight f6 wait what's not not what's
what's sorry sorry-sorry sorry-sorry
what's what's what's what's happening
okay Geoffrey Jean got away with one
there got away with one there okay he's
down a little bit of time here with the
two pieces just takes and check and oh
my gosh he is so fast okay Wow and
somehow he's picking up the route the
rook now he's just up a piece but he's
still down time he's down too much time
oh gosh she's just down too much time
he's just down too much time that's
that's a that's a tough one right there
that's a tough one and it looks like
penguin is back in the match as well and
this is aa ah
what is this format okay Geoffrey back
in the game against Daniel I'm just
gonna follow Geoffrey's Kim okay 97
Queen e2 would have been the funniest
move but it wasn't it wasn't played
Queen you - of course threatens
checkmate there okay 95 is a move Queen
h4 instead Bishop g5 maybe leaned back
to g3 draw greed draw greed okay no draw
greed dunya once more okay that hangs
upon though takes back Bishop f4 this
King doesn't feel happy this King
doesn't feel happy where is the
compensation you you have the weaker
King and fewer pawns
I don't understand okay yeah just the
simple retreat Knight takes no hits this
rook f3 fix this night Geoffrey is kind
of consolidated with his extra pawn here
and it's e4 he's just trading off a
little bit mean side castles avoiding
the open chief fire key one now
pressuring me six Queen h6 goes after
this f6
okay f4 f5 seems natural doubling also
seems natural 'if I've ok just free pond
on h7 I love it
free pond on age seven bishops attacks
pawn takes maybe Bishop takes you
actually okay what is happening that
move is checkmate oh my god
oh my god but this move is check this
move is checked but then rook takes but
then check but then takes okay
Danya found found a nice little tack oh
my god pawn takes Geoffrey Zhang is a
genius for pawns for the bishop four
pawns for the bishop got to start
pushing these guys okay with the extra
pawns Wow okay I really would have
traded rooks there because I just like
to simplify things
maybe Geoffrey likes his chances with
the rooks on the board and you can start
to see why here these pawns have made it
so far will they make it far enough Rick
sixty five is a threat rook takes T 5
right xt v g7 yes Geoffrey Zhang gets
the Queen but he's down on time oh my
god go fast Geoffrey take the rook
oh you can't take the rook he's gonna
lose this game
unbelievable
all right Geoffrey strong winning on the
board in both of these games but losing
the game and we lose that one 16 to 14
somehow god only knows how is the next
one in progress is the next one it's
over it's over in progress it's over the
match is over
who won nobody knows
I have no idea what the final score is
things got a little bit hazy there
because the matches were starting before
the previous matches ended and then you
can't really join late so I'm a little
bit unclear on on who actually won all I
know is I had some fun commentating all
these games it was a blast being here
you guys hopefully you enjoyed as well a
little bit unfortunate that the format
took such a such a wild turn but I had a
good time st. Louis won you guess maybe
I'm not so certain the score here is 16
to 14 the last score posted in the chat
was like 102 and a half an hour favored
to one and a half for 101 and a half for
them but obviously those scores don't
add up to 128 and a half it's uh it's I
don't I don't know so stay tuned for the
[Music]
for the final results I guess if such a
thing can can even be determined we lost
this one 16 to 14 so st. Louis won he
says st. Louis won I don't know why why
do you guys all think we won so much st.
Louis lost by one point stay on the air
till we figure this out okay I'm here
I'm here for you guys
we're working through it meanwhile who
played these games penguin lost a game
is it is it true can it be
penguin lost a Bullock in crazy h4 h5 ok
this this is this is now we're Chesson
now we're Chesson I love it shove all
the pawns up the board give checks take
take pawns this is this is the type of
nonsense games that that I was seen
earlier today ok and all of a sudden her
rooks hanging all of a sudden her rook
singing and then c2 hangs and that hangs
and then check and then b7 but then this
and then
you know my gosh now why it's just
crushing all of a sudden or it takes g6
it's nice the H pawn would Queen and
then more checks and checkmate excellent
stuff so the unofficial score is 116 and
a half to 117 and a half in favor of
Charlotte that is a really really close
match actually really close stuff it was
a lot of fun the problem is obviously
neither of those points adds up to 128
and a half now I imagine this happened
because the matches were starting before
the previous matches ended and so due to
that not all of the players where in all
of the matches but you know I think in
my opinion at least you know I'm not in
charge of these things it makes sense
that we just score the games that were
played and it looks like we ended up
down a point that's that's tough we were
so close in those two games in the final
match Jeffrey was just dominating in
both positions and just a hair too slow
just a hair too slow unfortunately but
I'm sure there were countless games that
went the other way with that as well
countless games
so I will wait for the official word
from been here and been I believe is
keeping track of all of the things and
is in close contact with Mike what
happened
Eric things went a little bit crazy it
looked like some matches we're starting
before the previous matches had ended
and so not everybody were in there
not everybody managed to join everything
yeah people couldn't join so we didn't
get to the 128 and a half that we were
we were hoping for in fact of the games
that were actually played it looks like
Charlotte beat us by a single point
Julian was -1 so it's obviously all
Julian's fault if Julian had scored 50%
we would have tied the match just
kidding just just kidding it's all a
joke forfeits our dud judged as double
forfeits the sort stands Charlotte wins
okay so I think that's the fairest way
to do it I I endorse that judgment here
everything just went too crazy with with
the forfeits and double forfeits and and
the people not joining so the final
score is 116 and a half for st. Louis
one seventeen and a half two Charlotte
they just barely beat us out there it
was a lot of fun hopefully you guys
enjoyed this match hopefully we have
more matches to come in the future
against Charlotte I had a great time
commentating these obviously it's it's
all craziness but hopefully you guys had
a great time watching as well that's
going to do it for us here on this live
coverage of the event thank you all so
much for joining me
be sure to stay tuned tomorrow when we
always have more chess content coming
your way each and every day until then
my name is